[BIRDS CHIRPING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
RONALD REAGAN:
Ladies and gentlemen,
students of Hillsdale, the
friends of the College,
I'm delighted to be here
the first time, although I
have been well acquainted for
a long time with what Hillsdale
means.
DAVID M. WHALEN: You are
men and women of Hillsdale,
steeped in the best traditions
of our great nation.
If you don't lead by
example, who will?
LARRY ARNN: The College was
founded for four things--
freedom, faith,
learning, and character.
If you read the 1844 document
in beautiful language,
that's what it says.
SPEAKER: Your education
in the liberal arts
has empowered you to conserve
the foundations of our freedom.
And you are now
uniquely suited, and I
believe you are uniquely
called to renew the fabric
of our national life.
It will require courage
and tenacity and greatness
of spirit.
At times, you will
face opposition.
But as you've learned
here at Hillsdale,
strength rejoices
in the challenge.
LARRY ARNN: The term "education"
comes from a Latin term that
means to "lead forth," educare.
And "forth" is the
interesting part, right?
Because you have to
know which way is forth.
And forth is a value term.
There's back.
And there's decline,
and there's decay,
and there's forth and rising.
The source of the crisis in
our country is in education.
Some philosophers invented a
new way of looking at the world.
And then this new
way, they thought,
we are actually not a thing with
a nature touched by the divine.
Instead, what we are is
a kind of evolving thing.
And that turned education
away from what it used to be,
to be an exercise to try to
control influences on us.
Well, Thomas Jefferson
writes of the laws of nature
and of nature's God, it is the
way of things and knowing them,
and then being able to
see your part in things.
And that makes us responsible
for ourselves in a bigger way.
It takes energy to learn.
It takes focus.
You have to give yourself to it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSH: My name is Josh.
I'm from Pella, Iowa.
RYAN: I'm Ryan from
Temecula, California.
NATE: My name is Nathan.
I'm from Oshkosh, Wisconsin.
RITA: My name is Rita, and
I am from Nairobi, Kenya.
CALEB: My name is Caleb, and
I'm from Holland, Michigan.
CLARA: My name is Clara,
and I'm from Cincinnati.
I was always planning
to go to music school.
Coming to Hillsdale was
kind of a big shift for me.
CALEB: I was recruited by a
lot of Division II schools
to go and play football.
A lot of them felt
the same, but when
I stepped foot on
Hillsdale, I just
knew it was a different place.
RYAN: My sister and
I were home-schooled.
Some people always ask me,
whoa, do you have friends?
How did you socialize?
RITA: When I first decided
to come to Hillsdale,
my parents and I had to
make some hard choices.
Leaving the country
as a 20-year-old
was a hard thing to do.
And (CHOKING UP) I really
respected my parents
in letting me do this.
Sorry.
I'm kind of tearing up.
[CHUCKLES]
NATE: When I had made the
decision to come to Hillsdale,
I knew nothing about what
the liberal arts were.
JOSH: It was hard for
me to first understand,
how is this practical?
How is this useful?
RYAN: Everything in
life is intertwined,
and that's what the liberal
arts experience captures.
CLARA: Just the idea
that it takes a lot more
than one discipline to make you
into a well-educated person.
NATE: It doesn't just
seek to develop skills
in a specific area,
but to develop
the character of the individual
and the ability to learn.
DAVID M. WHALEN: What a
human being has to do,
strange as it
sounds, a human being
has to be taught
to see the world.
We don't actually see reality
very clearly if we're just
left to our own devices.
We entertain all kinds
of wishful thinking.
A liberal education
liberates people
from all those constraints on
their understanding reality.
DIANE PHILLIPP: It's a time
when college-aged students are
really making more
choices probably
than any other
time in their life.
We have to help them understand
how to reach towards the good.
Those are the kind of people
that other people follow.
Those are leaders.
LARRY ARNN: It's very hard
to take an 18-year-old
and help them become an
educated 21-year-old adult.
It's a pain on
everyone involved.
[CHUCKLES]
It's also great.
And the point is
you orient yourself
around a combination of
surveying the necessary things
and digging deeply
into the best things.
But you got to read philosophy
and rhetoric and logic
and economics, politics,
and history, and literature.
And you've got to study
math, chemistry, biology,
and physics.
And so that means that
you're addressing yourselves
to the great subjects that
make up human knowledge.
And there, that's
an achievement,
to be a person when somebody
says, what do you need to know?
Wouldn't it be great to
have an answer to that?
And one can have an answer.
Hillsdale College was founded
on the frontier in 1844,
and it was founded by a bunch
of Free Will Baptist preachers
who came out here on the
frontier to start a college.
DAVID M. WHALEN: They were very
serious about high learning
and about the
perpetuation of freedom,
and very much founded the
school from its beginning
to admit people of
any race, both sexes.
So it was pretty radical.
LARRY ARNN: And they rode
their horse into various towns,
and the one who came here is
a man named Ransom Dunn, who
worked here for 50 years.
Ransom Dunn rode into
Hillsdale, and he said,
I'd like to meet with
the citizens interested
in education.
And so they met
in the city hall,
but it didn't have anything
to do with government.
Interesting point,
to enter the college,
you had to read Latin and Greek.
And if you didn't
read those things,
they started a prep school
where you could just
learn those things, and then
you could come to college.
Why?
They're going to read the
old books, the classic books,
the first books written in
the West, of philosophy.
And the Bible, the
New Testament's
in Greek, and so it's
intellectually very ambitious.
This is going to be
a serious college.
a Christian college.
This is going to be
a freedom college.
This college is not
going like slavery.
DAVID M. WHALEN: So much so,
that during the Civil War,
the College almost closed.
So many students up
and joined the Army.
The College was kind of a
ghost college for a while.
There were just very
few students left.
Of course, they realized
that these students are just
doing exactly what we
believe is most important,
and that is defending
the country,
defending the unity
of the country,
and looking to end slavery,
this terrible moral blot
on the country.
The College then, after
the war, when most colleges
and universities in the
country were taken up
in the sort of heady days
of educational reform,
Hillsdale never lost sight
of its founding principles,
and thought, we don't
actually have the liberty
to cashier our principles
and rewrite the nature
and mission of the institution.
And then, of course,
in the 1950s,
the federal government started
funding higher education.
And Hillsdale College was one of
the very few perhaps eccentric
institutions that
said, nope, nope, nope,
we're not going to do it.
Hillsdale College understands
its independence is essentially
preserved by not
becoming a branch
of the federal government.
LARRY ARNN: The
biggest detriment
of not taking money is one
doesn't have the money.
[CHUCKLES] The
biggest benefit is it
reminds you what you're for,
and we focused on our mission
around here.
The people who
support the College--
just think about that--
they don't get anything for it.
They support the College because
they love the kind of thing
it is.
DAVID M. WHALEN:
Hillsdale College
was founded as a
Christian college.
It remains a Christian
college, of course.
There is some tendency to think
that a Christian college means
a college that has foreclosed
important questions
and is really a kind of
indoctrination institution.
Quite the reverse, it
opens the education up
to the ultimate point
at which everything
comes to be fully
meaningful and integrated.
LARRY ARNN: You can't have
a liberal arts education
without God, because
you would have
to do without the
idea of the perfect.
And sure enough, by logic,
that would deprive you
of understanding why anything
is higher than anything else.
And so come to find
out the idea of God
is the motive toward
which all learning moves.
Our college motto is "Strength
rejoices in the challenge."
And what does that mean?
It means it's a
rigorous undertaking
to try to know the best things
and live according to them.
DIANE PHILLIPP: Some people
smile about our model,
that "Strength rejoices in the
challenge," but it's so true.
Life is a challenge,
and if they don't
go through challenging
times here,
they're not going to
be prepared for life.
NATE: The value that
was instilled in me
the most by my family
was the hard work ethic.
RITA: I grew up in a Christian
family, strong in faith
and strong as people.
CALEB: My parents instilled in
me a very strong work ethic.
They taught me
anything's possible
if you're willing to go get it.
JOSH: "Strength rejoices in
the challenge" is in many ways
a battle cry for Hillsdale.
RYAN: There are a lot of
times when the motto "Strength
rejoices in the challenge"
confuses me, because I'm
definitely not feeling strong.
[CHUCKLES]
CLARA: Freshman
and sophomore year,
maybe I did not rejoice
in the challenge
quite as much as I have
the last couple of years.
[LAUGHING]
RYAN: I'm feeling like there
are three papers to do,
several books to read,
and I don't know how
I'm going to get it all done.
JOSH: As someone preparing
himself to be a Marine officer,
this war cry of "Strength
rejoices in the challenge"
is so important.
The places that are
the most uncomfortable
are sometimes the best
places to be because of how
they challenge and grow you.
CLARA: There is just
an accomplishment
that you feel that
you don't feel
when things aren't as hard.
RITA: Just coming
from a place that
trains you to embrace
these challenges,
it's a skill that you'll use
every single day of your life.
CALEB: Whether it be
in the academic circle
where I didn't quite get the
grade I wanted on a paper,
or whether it be in sports,
where I thought I would come in
and be a starter one day.
But I've seen myself
more in a backup role.
You can see those
things as failures,
or you can see them as
opportunities to get better.
RYAN: You're not going
to get strong in a day.
But eventually, if you
keep working at it,
you're going to reach your goal.
JOSH: It requires to
embrace the challenges,
to embrace the suck, as
the Marine Corps would say.
NATE: Hillsdale College
is a very demanding place.
There are numerous amount
of challenges that we face,
and the hardest probably
being the balancing
of a lot of good things.
Through that process,
you fail a lot,
but you learn
through that failure.
RYAN: The purpose of "Strength
rejoices in the challenge"
is to build you into a better
person by the time you leave.
[MUSIC PLAYING]